[Music]
imagine a great king dressed in Royal
robes
this King were walking along the beach
and he saw his child drowning in the
water
when he immediately dive in to save his
child
what his Royal robes matter to him
no all that would matter to him at that
moment would be the child he loves
that's how great human love is
how much greater do you think God's love
is
in the New Testament Christians are
commanded to be humble
but the example we're given of true
humility was of a great king laying
aside his glory
diving into the world to save his
children
in Philippians we read
in your relationships with one another
have the same mindset as Christ Jesus
who being in very nature God did not
consider equality with God something to
be used to his advantage
rather he made himself Nothing by taking
the very nature of a servant being made
in human likeness
and being found in appearance as a man
he humbled himself by becoming obedient
to death even death on a cross
therefore God exalted him to the highest
place and gave him the name that is
above every name that at the name of
Jesus every knee should bow in heaven
and on Earth and under the Earth and
every tongue acknowledged that Jesus
Christ is Lord
to the glory of God the Father
this passage like the rest of the New
Testament and even the Old Testament
describes Jesus as God and yet draws a
distinction between Jesus and the father
which is why the Bible can only be
understood in light of the doctrine of
the Trinity the doctrine that God is one
in essence and yet exists eternally as
three Divine persons Father Son and Holy
Spirit
in John 6 38 Jesus the Divine son
tells his followers that he came down
from heaven
but why would he come down here
where is the Sun going when he left
heaven and came to Earth as Jesus of
Nazareth
was he going to Bethlehem
was he going to the cross
was he going to the tomb
was he going full circle leaving Heaven
only to return there later
though Jesus went to all of these places
he had a particular destination in mind
he tells us exactly where he was going
the last two verses of John 17 where he
says to the father
righteous father
though the world does not know you I
know you
and they know that you have sent me
I have made you known to them and will
continue to make you known in order that
the love you have for me may be in them
and that I myself may be in them
and that I myself may be in them in who
in us
we were Jesus destination when he left
heaven
in First Corinthians 6 19 the Apostle
Paul says
do you not know that your bodies are
temples of the Holy Spirit who is in you
Jesus died on the cross to cleanse new
temples for God's glory
because Jesus has a divine nature
he's the only man in history who could
take the full wrath of God
and then get up and walk away at his
resurrection
we were created to be the walking
talking living breathing temples of our
creator
but we sinned and fell short of the
glory of God
no matter how wonderful we think we are
nothing we could ever do
make us good enough to stand before God
we're going to dwell in the presence of
God and have God's presence within us
we need a righteousness that comes from
God not from ourselves
because all our righteous acts
are like filthy rags
the word gospel means good news
the good news is that God did something
for us
that we could never do for ourselves
for what the law was powerless to do
because it was weakened by the flesh
God did by sending his own son and the
likeness of sinful flesh to be a sin
offering
and so he condemned sin in the flesh in
order that the righteous requirement of
the law might be fully met in US
who did not live according to the flesh
but according to the spirit
we can now be the holy temples we were
created to be because we have the
righteousness of Christ
since there's nothing we can do to earn
this righteousness
we receive it by believing what God has
told us
for it is by Grace you have been saved
through faith
and this is not from yourselves
it is the gift of God
not by works
so that no one can boast
so confess with your mouth Jesus is Lord
and believe in your heart that God has
raised him from the dead
and you will be saved
we were all drowning in our sins my
friends
in fact
we had already drowned
the king of all Kings
dove in to save us
and that's the gospel
[Music]
foreign